اما اهل البيت الابيض لهيئات الحكوميه 30
يوما للتاكد من ازاله وحظر تطبيق تيك توك
على اي من الاجهزه او الانظمه التابعه
للحكومه الاتحاديه وذلك بسبب مخاطر
التطبيق المملوكي لشركه الصينيه على الامن
القومي الامريكي وفق ما يقوله الامريكيون
السلطات على منع استخدام تطبيق الصيني
لانها تعتبره
مبرمج لجمع بي
انات رسميه الامريكيه وصدر قرار مماثل قبل
ذلك من الحكومه الكنديه لانه كما قالت
ينطوي على مستوى غير مقبول من المخاطر
التي تتهدد الخصوصيه والامن كما حضرت
المفوضيه الاوروبيه التطبيق الاسبوع
الماضي على اجهزتها
وردا على حظر تطبيق تيك توك قالت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الصينيين الولايات المتحده
بصفتها اكبر قوه في العالم تخشى تطبيق
الذي يحبه الشباب وذلك انعدام للثقه
بالنفس وطالبت المتحدثه حكومه الولايات
المتحده باحترام مبادئ اقتصاد السوق
والمنافسه العادله كما شددت المتحدثه باسم
الخارج الصينيه على ان تايوان جزء لا
يتجزا من اراضي الصين منذ العصور القديمه
ومبدا صين واحده هو معيار اساسي معترف به
في العلاقات الدوليه واساس سياسي مهم
لاقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه مع الصين